he's using hot fluid to deal with the
carbon dioxide of our industrial age
there is an equally technical fix these
pipes valves and tanks at Imperial
College London can capture 500 tons of
the greenhouse gas every year scale up
the plant and it could trap carbon
emissions from whole power stations and
then store them underground only
political will is holding back is
rollout where you will then start to
remove co2 from the atmosphere and to an
in so doing you can offset emissions
from hard-to-reach point sources like
aviation or shipping or transport and
then in due course as we transition to a
Net Zero economy so we're not emitting
any greenhouse gases anymore you can
start net removing co2 from the
atmosphere and helping to clean up the
mess made by historical co2 emissions
but some scientists are so alarmed by
the pace of climate change that they're
considering even more radical fixes that
actually repair the climate a former
chief scientific adviser to the
government said reducing carbon
emissions to zero will take too long
more urgent action is needed the global
political system humanity as a whole has
not reacted to this enormous danger so
now we have to consider other means of
controlling our climate systems so it is
a sign of our failure to deal with the
problem it absolutely is a sign of our
failure options for cooling the earth
include aircraft flying at 60,000 feet
that create a cloud of sulfur dioxide to
shield us from the sun's heat ships that
pump saltwater into the sky to whiten
the clouds so they reflect more sunlight
back into space and allow polar ice to
reform and scattering iron fertiliser on
the sea to trigger a bloom of algae that
absorbs carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere back in the climate doesn't
get us off the hook we still need to
change our lifestyles to drive electric
to fly less to cut back on red meat the
science
clear to fix global warming we need to
stop pumping out so much carbon dioxide
engineering the climate could have
unintended consequences altered weather
patterns could cause droughts dimming
the Sun could reduce crop yields but
scientists are now so concerned by the
impact of global warming that many now
believe it's worth the risk
Thomas Moore Sky News